I love using this camera to me this is
probably one of the best Warframe
cameras I've used in years
really good in the hand
[Music]
and that's the thing of this camera it
is bang on
but it makes you appreciate what the z9
has to offer and the attention the
detail that Nikon has put into this
camera this is where the z9 is going to
come into play and it handles it
beautifully
hey everyone what's going on we're back
talking about a production version of
the Nikon z9 now we did a first
impressions video we'll put a link right
here but don't click on that just yet
because when we did have video a few
months back obviously it was a beta
version firmware was in final body was
pretty much final but we did take it
through its Paces we actually got
soaking wet at the bird park uh Zachy
you were drenched I was drenched we were
all drenched we had a lot of fun with
that camera and it was one of the best
cameras of 2021 in terms of full-frame
cameras I mean it's just is a true
hybrid AKB recording 4K 120 no
overheating two hours of AK recording
for that matter 45.7 megapixel full
frame sensor 20 frames per second in raw
30 frames in jpeg I mean this camera is
pretty much stacked so it's nice to
actually have a production version of
this camera to take it through its Paces
now I know a lot of you out there doing
birding and Wildlife Photography in
sports photography for this camera and
rightfully so it's designed for that but
as I mentioned this is a hybrid camera
so what we want to do is take it to a
different place a good friend of our
Josh from 25 degree Woodworks there's
there's Josh right there
we're actually going to capture him in
his in his element doing woodworking he
does some awesome chairs and some
different drawers and all these great
custom woodworking jobs that he does
we're in a caption doing all this with
the Nikon z9 video and photography plus
while taking a Lightroom and I'll show
you sample images from the 100 to 400 uh
4.5 to 5.6 to 24 120 which I have here
on the camera at Ford this is the new
s-line lens as well as a 2875 and of
course
my one of my favorite lenses of all time
the f-mount 105 1.4 beautiful portrait
lens anyway with that let's go down to
capturing Josh in his element let's do
it Josh
[Music]
now there's many different focusing
modes here on the z9 of course I usually
try to stay in wide L gives me reverse
utility but for something like this I
may want to go to a smaller uh focusing
point
to really capture the tools that have
been used here's the thing I know a lot
of people say that link on z9 with a
3.69 million.edf is it as high res as
other cameras and I mentioned this in my
first impressions but it's so sharp and
it is so clear it's almost it's better
than some 5.76
marine.edfs
even in lower light situations like this
is kind of low light in the shop
easy to see the detail absolutely easy
so I'm starting off with the all-new 24
120 F4 the new s line lens from Nikon
and this is a very versatile lens yes
it's F4 so that's something you have to
take in consideration for lower light
but this camera does very it produces
very great images in lower light
situations and this gives you a lot of
flexibility because case in point for
safety reasons I don't want to be too
close to Josh Aziz you know working on
this uh leg of this chair here but I can
get really close up
foreign
with this 120
and it's bitingly sharp the weight is
actually very light on the you know
Nikon z9 because this is actually not
the lightest camera in the market as we
talked about earlier
but once you get used to the ergonomics
are so good it feels really good in the
hand
[Music]
for those of you know this lens you know
this lens this is
one of those dream lenses it's a heavy
lens uh we'll put the weight right here
because I can't remember off the top of
my head and the quartz is mounted with
the new ftz adapter the Mark II version
of this so you don't have that kind of
square thing in the bottom and they kind
of redesign it to fit the z9
but this lens performs beautifully on
the z9 if you're worried about adapting
F note lenses do not be this is an
awesome lens compared to this
autofocusing is just as fast as native
lenses but the bokeh the fall off the I
mean you know what this lens is about I
don't need to explain it to you guys
and uh even though it's been it's been
out for a few years you think it could
resolve the Nikon z9 sensor yes it is
stunning
other reviewers have talked about it as
well and even right now I'm shooting
against the light right there you see
the light on his mask and there's no
flaring coming into play there's no
ghosting or anything everything is well
controlled with this lens
for this portion of the video I'll be
shooting a lot here to kind of capture
these moments but after that we'll go
into Lightroom I'm going to show you
images I've taken at the zoo with my
friend Alan he was had a BMW m440i on
loan for a couple days we shot some
images of that some other shots that
I've taken uh if we go boss and all that
great stuff so yeah let's get back to
shooting Josh
creating his work of art
the ultimate chair right Josh yeah
[Music]
so this was interesting because as Josh
was using the plane right there he was
going fast at times and other times he
was going slow so I was trying to track
him and I was noticing the tracking was
working relatively well in his hands
because he was going so fast it also
does sometimes will miss a few shots
um and here's the thing about this Nikon
z9 which kind of throws me a little bit
I'm still getting used to this camera
it's only a bit of three a few weeks but
you really gotta know you're focusing uh
settings and understanding how they work
on the camera system because I mean you
can set the automatic but it's not
always going to track exactly what you
want or what focusing wide L wide small
do you want 3D uh tracking do you want
to just let it you know figure out on
its own or do you want to you know pick
a particular point and it's also these
small settings inside the menu system
the sub settings that really will help
you get the shot that you want to
achieve and there's a lot of videos and
tutorials out there online but it's this
is a camera that you're gonna have to
spend a lot of time with so I mean
unfortunately on the camera for a few
weeks here for review I don't have a
long-term loan on it but it is something
that I can see the the potential is
definitely there I love using this
camera to me this is probably one of the
best full-frame cameras I've used in
years
but it's one of those things you've got
to spend a lot of time with to
understand the nuances of the z9 to
capture the shot that you want to
capture especially in fast action or
kind of tighter situations all right so
Josh is going to hollow out the seat of
a chair
you have no idea what goes into making a
chair we have to haul out the C4 because
some people's butts are bigger than
others yeah yeah see someone like me who
has no ass whatsoever is just flat just
flat
it is don't do a butt shot at me Zacky I
know that's coming up
[Music]
now here's the thing we're using the 100
to 400 to 4.5 to 5.6 right brand new
lens from Nikon and a lot of people are
excited about this lens birding Wildlife
photography sports but it's also great
in a situation like this for a 100 at
4.5 you're able to capture a lot of
details pretty good close focusing on
this as well so I may be able to capture
as he's working on this piece of wood
and this lens is bitingly sharp I mean
all Z lenses are really good this lens
is exceptional so if you're looking for
a good 100 to 400 right you can use that
enough Mount version of this trust me
move on to this it is absolutely
fantastic
all right Josh
that's the thing about a 100 or 400 you
want to shoot this you got to get far
back even at 100
because he's going to use this what's
the tool called again ads and ads
ads okay
video bets speaking of ads here's a
message from our sponsor this video is
brought to you by secret lab here at
geek culture we love our secret lab
chairs especially the all-new 2022 Titan
Evo with its revamped four-way lumbar
system for enhanced back support
new leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea
then consider the all new soft weave
even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colors
including this lovely Frost Bloom the
Titan Evo is even magnetized allowing
the head pillow to stick on the headrest
without straps of course there are even
more new features so do check them out
at seekerlab.co
so using this over the past few weeks
the one thing I do enjoy is the fact
that these buttons do light up and these
are small things but they do come in
handy often when we're shooting a lower
light situation so
a lot of things on Pro cameras nowadays
are not doing that some of the older
dslrs did it but some of the pro
mirrorless cameras don't have this and
it's nice that Nikon actually brought
this into the z9 because if I'm shooting
in my home studio and I'm doing video
and I need to adjust the settings I just
can turn on the light see the menu
button see where it's at or the play
button and I can actually access it
without needing to get a flashlight and
see in the back of the camera or even if
you're an events photographer a wedding
photographer you're in a lower light
situation and you don't want to you know
press something wrong or fidget or bring
out a flashlight to see your settings
that button that switch here on the top
where you can actually just access the
the lighting mechanism on this works
wonders small things like that but it
makes you appreciate what the z9 has to
offer and the attention the detail that
Nikon has put into this camera and
that's why I've really just enjoyed
using it for the most part I mean the
size is going to weigh on you literally
it's a heavier camera and for some
people out there it may be too heavy for
daily usage but if you are the type of
photographer or videographer that wants
that kind of true hybrid function
personality 8K video recording don't
want to worry about overheating or if
you want to take it into a rough terrain
like this with dust and all different
debris around here and not worry about
the camera you know failing on you this
is where the z9 is going to come into
play and it handles it beautifully
[Music]
[Music]
all right so we talked about photos for
a second let's talk about video but you
know what we're going to go into a
montage that Zaki shot and edited and
you guys know the specs of the z9 it's
on the website and many other videos
I've talked about it we'll show you real
world footage and let you be the judge
if the z9 is the video camera for you
[Music]
remember girls in Mississippi
get along so I can see
[Music]
from way down Tennessee
[Music]
saying it shouldn't but she always
[Music]
so as you start from the video footage
it looks awesome great dynamic range
great stabilization exactly can you
attest to that hell yeah yeah it's
awesome I mean of course you've got a
larger body so that it's going to help
with stabilization but no issues
shooting 4K 120 uh if any frame rate in
4k even 8K for that matter no
overheating okay thing of the past but
you got to get a larger camera for that
to happen anyway
that's it for video now we're going to
jump into Lightroom we're going to show
you images I've taken with all these
lenses here at 25 degree Woodworks as
well as in the zoo outside shooting jobs
all that great stuff let's check out
those images right now all right guys
we're now in Lightroom take a look at
images here from the Nikon z9 through
various different uh photo sessions I've
had with the camera some professionals
some for fun also in Josh's Workshop as
you saw from the uh the video earlier on
that we've been taking photos at so
let's look through some of the images
that I shot first with and this is the
zoo and of course I love taking the
Nikon z9 to the zoo with a 100 400 this
is a great combination uh the focal
length is great that um 100 to 400 is
perfect for most Zoo scenarios unless
depending on where what zoo you're at
but I think anything beyond five to six
hundred would be an Overkill and also
quite hard to carry around but again it
depends on your photography style anyway
let's look at some images here I took a
picture of this lioness here and this is
really
um really spectacular just the detail
that you get out of these uh this lens
with this 100 or 400 paired with the z9
sensor is just awesome and I love the
color science from Nikon I think with
the greens and the yellows and just the
in nature it really just comes alive and
I think this is why a lot of people love
using this camera system because the
colors that you get now when you're
shooting raw not everything's going to
look the same way right this is what it
looks like before any edit okay the as
you can see the background is a little
bit more brighter you can see there's a
bit of Shadow falling on the face of the
line and around here the neck area and
you know you want your subject to pop
out so what I do is I go into Lightroom
here and I'll play around with the
subject masking make the line pop out
darken the background a little bit just
so we have where my focus wants to be
and of course I brighten up areas here
with the shadow chosen uh you know
exposures and I play around with it with
a little bit of dodging and burning then
from there I'll go into Photoshop clean
it up a little bit more and then
possibly into luminar AI or luminar Neo
since it just came out and I'll do the
my final touches there so I'll show you
what the final image looks like here but
to give you an idea there's a lot of
play in these files which is great the
dynamic range is awesome especially in
low isos of these files it's just so
much play in these images it's really
really spectacular okay let's go into
another image here of this tiger and
this was an interesting image this was
something when I first took the image I
was very unsure of and I'll tell you why
this is what it looked like
as you can see half his faces and
shadows uh
it's dark I'm thinking oh great what am
I going to do with this image however
because I was shooting at ISO 180
I got a lot of play so I can expose you
know I can boost up the Shadows here the
exposures put around the lighting on the
eyes the fur uh the Water a little bit
and this is just my first step then I go
into Photoshop and then I finalize it
but I was really happy with the overall
results now you're thinking why did I
shoot a 1000 uh one over 1250 and
I gotta tell you the reason is because
the tiger was moving around quite a bit
it looks like he was staying perfectly
still but he actually wasn't he was
moving around he was playing in the
water a little bit and he was constantly
moving and I'm hand holding this 100 to
400 with the Nikon z9 which is a heavy
setup so just to be sure that I got the
shot in focus and it's tack sharp I was
willing to sacrifice a little bit on the
iso to get that shot so
um I will show you some samples later on
where I'm cranking it up a little bit
more but yeah this is in essence why
that shutter speed is so high and yeah
it works relatively well very very happy
with the image I mean look just how
detailed the fur is here it just so tack
sharp it is awesome to see anyway I'll
show you what the final image looks like
now
and yeah I'm very very happy with that
now let's move on to a shoot that I did
with my friend Alan with the BMW the
m440i coupe and let's talk about some of
these images here
this was shot with the uh 105 to 1.4 ISO
125.
um now this is an older lens of course
and when you compare it to the Z lenses
the Z lenses will be sharper but this is
a very impressive lens even uh on you
know an older lens on the z9 it works
beautifully and of course this is my
first stage of the edits I will show you
what the final edit looks like here
of course in the final edit I added a
little bit of uh you know glow to the
headlights and just made it pop a little
bit more button cleaned up the car a
little bit but uh very very happy with
the overall results and I mean the
colors out of it is awesome this is what
it looked like before edit and this
would look like after edit
all right now let's look at this shot
here this is a little bit at Sunrise
okay just as the sun was creeping up
here and
there is a mistake that I made on this
and this is it happens to all of us so
I'm going to show you the mistake is
that I cranked up the shutter speed way
too high the car isn't moving the 105
1.4 you can still hand hold this lens
with the Ibis inside the camera this was
a mistake I made happens ISO 1600 uh
this should have been a lot lower and
this should have been a lot cleaner of
an image my mistake but I was able to
salvage a lot of this uh through
Photoshop and through topaz denoise so I
ended up actually using this image
instead
and then after my final edit it looked
like this
but this is what it looks like before
edit as well so as you can see there's a
lot of play in the images and I play
around with the colors of the greens a
little bit I don't like too green all
the time some people do some people
don't but I wanted more that Autumn feel
but yes let's move on to a couple other
images here uh this is the image I was
really happy with because I wanted to
capture this shot where we had Delvin
who is a basketball player here in
Singapore where this is for a shoot for
her boss uh for their NBA line and I
wanted him to spin the ball but I wanted
his face to be still and this is pardon
parcel with the Ibis that's inside the
z9 how good it is but yeah I stopped
this down to F16 on this because I
wanted to you know obviously keep the
exposure in line but here's what it
looked like originally so it was
Overexposed I was able to bring back a
lot of it here and the detail in the
background as well and here is my final
edit here
to show you what I did with it this
image took me a little bit more uh work
because of the time of day I was
shooting this around 2 p.m bright
daylight not my optimal time that I
would love to shoot any photos but
that's that's the time that we were
allotted with the basketball players so
I had to work what I had and but overall
I'm happy with the image let's move on
to a couple other images here if you
want to just see a dog because we always
love dog shots right here anyway this is
great I put it on animal eye tracking
um Works fantastic capture the dog's
eyes absolutely awesome detailed this is
before edit and here's
after edit before edit and after edit
just sort of accentuated the eyes a
little bit more and just sort of
darkened in the background here so the
dog pops out and I'm really happy with
this again the eye tracking on this
camera system if it's humans if it's
dogs or animals or cars it's spot on it
really is good I mean it's a it's right
up there with the best so if you're
worried about that do not be and other
videos I've talked about this in linked
as well okay let's go into Josh's
workshops real quick and let's take a
look at some of the images here I'm
going to show you some higher ISO
performance images
um now here's the thing uh depending on
your comfort level you know this
camera's ISO performance is decent it is
I don't think I would go anything above
10 000 or 12 800 even though this is 12
800 here and you can see a lot of detail
if you don't have noise reduction
software you're probably not going to
like a lot of this unless you like that
kind of grainy look but it is usable
it's just something that I have to put
this in perspective that not everybody
likes noise in their image so I'm keep
that in mind now I ran this through
topaz denoise and it cleaned it right up
but still this is pretty impressive I
mean there's still a lot of detail here
in his 3M pads on his face mask you
could see this here through his T-shirt
and the reason I had I was cranking up
the eyes uh the shutter speed to win
over 1000th of a second is I wanted to
capture the wood chips flying off as he
was grinding here and this is what the
the 24 120 F4 and it's a beautiful image
in terms of the how it all comes about
right let me show you what it looks like
before edit and this is a color now you
can see the noise is a lot is a lot
heavier here when you're in color of
course when you drop it back to black
and white some of the detail does come
back into play but yes it is something
to take note of and again everyone's uh
limitations will be different but I
think this would be the max I would go
for on this camera system
and it doesn't always work sometimes it
might be even too high for what you need
okay let's look at another image here
let's look at this port shot this is
more of a lower ISO ISO 2000 and I'm
going to say these low ISO numbers even
1600 to 2000 they're very clean and
ample light look at this when we look at
Josh's face right here very clean image
very usable image okay
um again the lighting situation in the
workshop was a little bit off so yeah
you know I put a 1 over 400th of a
second you're thinking why over one or
four hundredth of a second when he's
standing still this guy does not stand
still Josh if you're watching this video
thank you so much but you move around
like a speed demon so I say okay Josh
Stand still and you get a second he
moves second he moves and so you're like
okay I want to make sure this shot is in
Focus so you got to crank up the shutter
speed with him I'll show you some other
images what I talk I mean by that even
something like this right I'm testing
the tracking on this he's moving quick
so 1 over 500th of a second to capture
this image with the 2875 it's sharp
right here it Nails it but there is
going to be some uh noise creeping in
because he's moving so fast as he's
doing these things
um you'll get I mean in some of the
video shots you may see this but he
balances around like crazy he's full of
energy fantastic guy but uh as a result
depending on your subject you can ask
him to slow down but if they're in their
mode they're in their work
um Mojo it's hard to tell people to slow
down sometimes you know what I mean so
that's where you gotta have a good
camera with decent ISO performance the
z9 captures it and with some topazy
noise the final image will look like
this
uh this is at ISO 1600 I changed this to
black and white this is what it looks
like in color and I wanted to capture
the wood chips flaking flying off here
and you know black and white to me just
it just pops with this teach their own
you may like or dislike but I was really
happy with this again with the 24 120
one over eight hundredths of a second at
F4 and yeah really really happy with
that let's do this to the 105 1.4 this
is one over 100th of a second and ISO
450 again clean image very sharp uh I
love it you know this lens is a
beautiful lens the dream lens people
that own it know what I'm talking about
and I just love the separation that you
get out of it of course I changed the
colors a little bit brought down the
exposure in some areas and I'm really
really happy with the end results
all right so yeah I mean I think the z9
is a fantastic performing camera you've
got to know understand how to work with
the settings you got to know its
limitations
um but if you are looking for a camera
that's a very versatile camera system
with decent ISO performance I think
you're going to be very impressed with
what this camera delivers anyway let's
go to my final thoughts on the z9 okay
let's talk about my um final thoughts on
the z9 because I've there's been a lot
of videos out on YouTube and I've
watched pretty much I wouldn't say about
80 of them I'm a big fan of this camera
and before I went into this video I
wanted to approach it in a very
different way I know there's a ton of
videos out there in terms of birding and
Wildlife photography and Sports
Photography and better and the best way
to set up the camera for focusing in
various different uh scenarios and this
is not what I wanted to do with this
video I want to talk about this as a
general camera system that also can do
those things because it's designed for
that and do it really well but also from
your just your average photographer your
day-to-day photographer your
videographer out there how how does this
camera fit into your lifestyle is it
worth the investment or is it worth
getting something else and you know one
thing that always struck me about using
the z9 especially with this version of
because I got to dig deeper into the
usage of the camera and I've had it more
than a day when I had when we did versus
our first impressions was that this is
really a true hybrid camera without
compromises and let me explain a little
bit further what I mean by that the Sony
Alpha One when that came out to market
last year uh that was a 50 megapixel up
to 30 frames per second beast up to 8K
video recording 4K et cetera Etc but it
did overheat especially when it comes
the video and in our climate here in
Singapore hot humid most of the time we
take it outside even we're shooting 4K
video it overheats and I was talking to
uh production offices that use it as
well and they were facing the same
situation part and parcel due to the
design of the camera it's not designed
for I mean it has heat dissipation etc
etc but it's not designed to withstand
that much heat right even when you set
the temperature to high temperature mode
it's still going going to overheat the
Canon R5 we already know about that
history don't need to go back into it
again the Canon R3 for that matter did
solve some of those issues I didn't
replace any overheating with that up to
6K video recording which is great if you
need that 4K is most what people are
going to be using or even 1080 when
you're using for Instagram or Facebook
but
um yeah it did solve a lot of the issues
um but of course it was only a 24
megapixel sensor so if you wanted a
higher megapixel sensor and you wanted
good video quality you still don't have
that quite yet from Canon okay Enter the
z9 two hour over two hours of 8K video
recording prores Ross coming in the near
future you've got n log you've got h.265
you've got uh various different modes in
this 4K 120 uh you've got up to 20
frames raw 30 frames jpeg 120 frames
jpeg 11 megapixels you've got a wide
spectrum of use cases for the z9 to
pretty much fit in any scenario that you
might come across as a photographer as a
videographer the only downside to the
camera I would say is the size of it and
the weight I mean it is a hefty camera
and this is sort of reminiscent of the
D5 and D6 or the 1dx3 for that matter
that you're dealing with a very robust
camera but the positive to that is that
if you're going to be out in the field
or you're going to be in some situations
where you might drop the camera knock on
wood that doesn't happen but if it does
you're going to be relatively safe with
the z9 I feel I think that it's built it
feels fantastic in the hand and it's
robust as hell so but the downside is
the weight we even put it on the DJI rs2
we try that out it's a hefty system it
works on the on the gimbal but it is
heavy so it's not something you're going
to want to carry for hours on end so you
might want to find a different rig set
up for that but it is there but the fact
of the matter is that you have a true
hybrid camera system with the pretty
much the best specs that you can get
into a a kind of a prosumer camera but
we'll call it that we're not talking
Cinema cameras here but prosumer camera
some of the best specs you're getting on
market price below the alpha one below
the R3
it's a really attractive package but
there is a star to that why is a price
lower well I think part and parcel
because of the CF Express type B cards
it just does not take UHS 2 cards and
uhs2 cards are significantly Less in
terms of price than CF Express type B
now type B is getting less expensive but
it is still a premium so if you're using
a 512 card you can look to spend
anywhere between five to seven hundred
dollars and if you want to go to a one
terabyte you're gonna go up towards a
thousand dollars thereabout so it is one
of those situations where you have to
take in consideration the cards and the
speeds of those cards and the price that
comes with it and I think that's why
nikoni kind of price the camera a little
bit lower makes it attractive to the
buyer when you first get into it but you
got to look at the smaller things and
price that in and go oh I see however as
having said that there is no card cards
for the uh the alpha one that match the
capacity of the CF Express type B cards
and doesn't see if Express type A is not
that high in terms of capacity and UHS 2
doesn't take take advantage of a lot of
the frame rates that you can with the
video and the high quality codex so it's
something to take note of
with the R3 you only get one at CF
Express type B card slot and uhs2 card
which is great for versatility but again
if you want to be redundant it's going
to be a little bit hard to do so with
that camera so the z9 does does cover
you in that regard so that's where it
really is a very unique package and I
think it's something that really struck
a chord with me and I'm glad that Nikon
brought out this camera kind of through
the kitchen sink at inside of this
because it's going to put them on a map
in a unique way and I think a lot of
people are very interested in the z9
that weren't interested in Nikon before
or maybe went to left Nikon went to Sony
and now I'm thinking to go back to Nikon
because of the system that they have the
lenses are fantastic I talked about the
24 to 120 in Lightroom a great lens but
it is F4 so keep that in mind the 100 or
400 is a phenomenal lens but you need
ample lighting for it 4.5 to 5.6 if
you're going to be at a high shutter
speed that no that ISO is going to creep
up really fast and that's going to take
an impact on the image quality of your
subject so that's something to do take
note of but in terms of the sharpness
and performance of the lens it is
awesome to use uh the 105 1.4 one of my
favorite lenses it works great on the z9
I'm not the only one that said this I
believe Matt Granger also talked about
this as well and it's a great lens it's
a beautiful portraiture lens and maybe
they will make a z version of this lens
one day who knows but even if they don't
the 105 1.4 is a dream but it is a heavy
lens the 2875 to me was a star lens in
terms of video even for photography it's
not an s-line lens but it's damn sharp
and it gives great performance most of
the videos that we showed that we shot
here for the channel when I was using
the z9 and talking to camera like I'm
doing right now was with the 2875
because it's really good it's fantastic
it's great versatility uh 2.8 straight
across and it's not that expensive it's
a pretty damn good lens a couple things
I want to point out to you guys menu
system I mean there are a lot a lot of
settings in the z9 people are doing
making videos 20 minutes long part three
part four part five going through the
the menu system to set up it for various
different scenarios
it is a little bit cumbersome and a lot
of it is a two three-step process the
one thing that kind of irks me and maybe
this is me just because I've only had
the camera for a couple weeks and had to
go back but
the iso if I want to get out of auto ISO
and I want to manually override it I
have to go into the menu and have to
select uh that auto ISO I forget what
the terminology is offhand I'd turn that
off then I have to go and then I can
manually set the iso there's no way for
me
to actually just go into the uh
information menu tap on the iso or even
the iso button on the camera and just
hit this move the dial and go right out
of auto ISO into manual ISO or override
it I wish they did that maybe this is
some there is a setting that I don't
know about and if there is let me know
in the comments section below but it was
a little bit frustrating that I had to
go through this multi-step process to do
that because sometimes I'm in a
situation where I'm like I don't want
the iso to be that high I want to bring
it down and then I've got to say hold on
a second give me a minute go into the
menu tap tap tap get out of it then I'm
good to go then I have to go back into
it 101 ISO auto ISO again a little bit
frustrating also in the information menu
system it's a two-step process this has
been part and parcel with Nikon
mirrorless cameras since they've gotten
into it but it's a little bit
frustrating when you're on the job and
you're like I need to move move my focus
uh choose a different Focus point or
choose something different I gotta tap
oh I can hit okay if I don't it's going
to stick to the same thing
it would be nice to just tap and go tap
and go tap and go and I wish there was a
setting that you could override that
maybe there is again and I don't know
but that's part and parcel with the how
deep this menu system goes that it's
very hard to find these things okay so
it's something I hope Nikon can sort of
simplify as time goes on make it a
little bit more user friendly uh because
yeah it's a little bit cumbersome in
that regard I would say the focusing
points I mean
it's it's really me having to find more
on this camera you know I still I stuck
to wide L for the most part in terms of
the tracking and kind of my go-to 3D
once in a while you know of course you
can adjust the tracking speeds and
everything else but I was always
fidgeting with the focus points a little
bit more than I was on other camera
systems and and I know that Nikon is
getting a lot better with her Auto
focusing system versus what they were
before and I'm I trust me this is a big
difference from the z72 and z62 big
difference right and it's right up there
with the Sony's and the canons but
you got to kind of play around with it a
little bit you've got to find that sweet
spot for you and I think for me even
with a few weeks I had the camera I was
still back and forth a few times trying
to figure out what worked in various
different scenarios Again part of parcel
with photography but I wish it was a
little bit more simplified in that
regard but I have to say the eye
tracking worked great the tracking as a
whole worked fantastic it works great on
cars works great on uh I mean just in
general it just it's a fantastic system
I mean you know I used all the other
cameras out there and it's right up
there with the best so uh no qualms at
all with that but I think the size for
the camera is going to probably be the
big factor for people are they going to
get the z9 or not I really do think
because it is the largest of the
mirrorless cameras out there right now
and it's something even for me when I'm
carrying it around in my bag I did feel
the weight especially with larger lenses
you do feel the weight after a while and
so this might not be a camera that I
would necessarily take on a trip with me
unless I'm doing it like a specific kind
of Photography and I need that kind of
body I would opt for a smaller body but
I mean
the image quality and the performance is
just so good it's one of these
sacrifices you're gonna have to make do
you take weight and size
you know and then have this great
hybrid camera or do you get a smaller
camera and then one or two it's gonna
have to give either photography or the
videography side of it so something to
take note of in that regard okay
something to take note of but I knew
overall I've really enjoyed the z9 it's
a great lifestyle portraiture camera
it's a great camera as a whole videos
are awesome out of it and I do highly
recommend it if you have the funds for
it it is going to be a camera that will
last you for a couple years Nikon is
very aggressive with their firmware
updates and I expect a lot more to be
coming in the near future anyway those
are my thoughts on the camera let me
know your thoughts in the comment
section below do you agree with me do
you disagree with me did I miss anything
out that I should have highlighted let
me know and I'll try to address that in
the near future with that guys follow us
on Facebook subscribe to us here on the
channel like this video it helps us out
a lot take care stay safe and I'll chat
to you soon
foreign
[Music]